WE WILL FOCUS ON POLICY.
NOT SCANDAL.
ELECTION IS A CHOICE, NOT JUST
BETWEEN TWO PEOPLE, BUT
BETWEEN TWO VISIONS OF AMERICA
AND TO POLICY.
EVERY SUNDAY WE WILL SET UP
THE CHOICE ON A DIFFERENT
ASPECT OF WHAT’S AT STAKE.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT
CORONAVIRUS.
HERE’S A CHOICE.
BASED ON THE FACTS AS WE ALL
KNOW, THE VIRUS STARTED IN
CHINA INITIALLY DENIED AND
COVERED UP BEFORE THEY LET THE
VIRUS SPREAD AROUND THE WORLD
EVEN AS THE REGIME SHUT DOWN
TRAVEL WITHIN CHINA.
HERE, AS WE KNOW, PRESIDENT
TRUMP UNDERSTOOD HOW SERIOUS
THIS WAS THERE IS A MASSIVE
POINT MISSING FROM THE MEDIA
OF HISTORICAL MISINFORMATION.
YES THE PRESIDENT’S PUBLIC
STATEMENTS WERE DESIGNED TO
AVOID PANIC.
SO WHERE DOCTOR COUNTY AND THE
CDC, EVEN THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN.
THEY WARNED AS LATE AS MID
FEBRUARY ABOUT A FEAR.
[INAUDIBLE]
MANY MORE LIES ABOUT.
WE COULD GO ON AND ON.
>> THAT WAS JAKE TAPPER
IMMEDIATELY AFTER A TRUMP
PRESS CONFERENCE LAST WEEK.
LATER IN THAT WEEK HE SAID
THIS ABOUT TRUMP.
HE WAVED THE WHITE FLAG.
HE DIDN’T DO A THING ABOUT
IT.
THINK ABOUT WHAT HE DID NOT DO
AND IT’S ALMOST CRIMINAL.
HE DIDN’T DO A DAMN THING.
REALLY?
ON JANUARY THE 29th THEY SET
UP THE TASK FORCE.
ON GENERATE 31st TWO BAND
TRAVEL FROM CHINA.
ON FEBRUARY THE SIXTH HE
ISSUED EMERGENCY RULES ON THE
INFECTION CONTROL.
THROUGHOUT THE NATION’S
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
ON FIGURE 24th HE WENT
CONGRESS FOR EMERGENCY
FUNDING.
ON FEBRUARY 29 HE EXPANDED
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS.
DAYS LATER HE RIPPED UP THE
RULEBOOK TO SORT OUT THE
TESTING FIASCO CREATED BY THE
BUNGLING CDC.
IF THE PRESIDENT HAD GOT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IN AT TOP SPEED
WITH BIDEN, WE’D PROBABLY
STILL BE WAITING ON HIS
PRECIOUS GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY TO GET IT DONE.
INSTEAD WE HAVE BY FAR THE
MOST TESTS IN THE WORLD AND
EVEN ON TEST.
POPULATION WERE SECOND ONLY TO
DENMARK.
LET’S CONTINUE.
ON MARCH 13, PRESIDENT TRUMP
DECLARED A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
JUST 48 HOURS AFTER A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC WAS DECLARED.
THE SAME DAY WE IMPOSED NEW
RESTRICTIONS TO PROTECT
NURSING HOMES.
ON MARCH 16 THE PRESIDENT
MOBILIZED THE WHOLE COUNTRY
AGAINST THE VIRUS.
15 DAYS TO SLOW THE SPREAD.
THAT WOULD BE BEFORE SHUTDOWN
WAS ANNOUNCED IN THE UK,
FRANCE, EVEN NEW ZEALAND WHICH
OUR MEDIA HOLDS UP AS HAVING A
PERFECT RESPONSE.
ON THE 17th HE LIFTED
RESTRICTIONS TO HELP PROTECT
SENIORS.
ON MARCH 18 HE INVOKED THE
DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT MAKE
SURE WE DIDN’T RUN OUT OF
HOSPITAL MASKS THAT WE NEEDED
MORE PPE SO HE LAUNCHED
PROJECT AIR BRIDGE TO FLY IN
SHIPMENTS OF SUPPLIES.
WE NEEDED MORE CAPACITY SO
WITHIN DAYS, HOSPITALS WERE
BUILT, SHIPS WERE SENT AND IN
THE END NOT EVEN USED.
WE NEED A VENTILATOR SO THE
PRESIDENT AGAIN INVOKED THE
PRODUCTION ACT TO GET THEM
MADE HERE IN AMERICA.
NOT A SINGLE PERSON WHO NEEDED
A VENTILATOR TO GET ONE, AND
NOW WERE SENDING THEM TO OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WE NEED EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS
ARE TRUMP SECURED MORE THAN
HALF A MILLION COURSES OF THE
MEDICATION.
TRUMP AND HIS TEAM GOT IT AND
KNOW THAT IS NOT FOX NEWS,
FAKE TV PROPAGANDA, IT’S THESE
GUYS.
>> THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
STEPPED UP AND WAS A GREAT
PARTNER AND I’M THE FIRST ONE
TO SAY.
WE NEEDED HELP AND THEY WERE
THERE.
>> CONVERSATION, COMMITMENT,
PROMISE MADE HIM A PROMISE
KEPT.
>> AGAIN NO THEY WEREN’T JUST
SAYING IT TO SUCK UP TO TRUMP
SO THEY GET STUFF FOR THEIR
STATE EITHER.
>> I’M NOT DOING IT TO KISS
THE RING, I’M NOT DOING IT IN
A WAY, I’M JUST BEING
FORTHRIGHT WITH THE PRESIDENT,
HE RETURNS CALLS, HE REACHES
OUT, HE’S BEEN PROACTIVE.
>> THANKS TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION UNPRECEDENTED
MOBILIZATION, WE FACED A VIRUS
BETTER EQUIPPED WITH BETTER
TREATMENT THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY AND YOU CAN SEE THE
EFFECTS OF THAT IN THE CASE
FATALITY RATE.
HERE IN AMERICA, IT WAS LOWER
THAN IN ANY OTHER MAJOR
COUNTRY.
HALF OF MUCH OF SPAIN.
LOWER THAN FRANCE AND DENMARK
AND GERMANY.
HELD UP AS THE BEST IN THE
WORLD, ALL THIS AND WE HAVEN’T
EVEN MENTIONED OPERATION WARP
SPEED WHICH COULD BE THE
BIGGEST DEAL OF ALL.
IT TOOK YEARS TO DEVELOP A
VACCINE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE IT A
PRIORITY FROM THE START.
HE GOT THE INDUSTRY TOGETHER,
HE CUT THROUGH THE
BUREAUCRACY, HE MADE TO THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES WERE
RIGHT.
IF THERE’S ONE MOMENT WHEN IT
REALLY MADE A DIFFERENCE
HAVING A BUSINESSMAN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, THIS WAS IT.
AS A RESULT WE COULD HAVE A
VACCINE IN WEEKS.
THESE ARE THE FACTS,
PREPOSTEROUSLY DESCRIBED BY
JOE BIDEN AS DOING NOTHING,
AND HERE WAS JAKE WITH HIS
FACT CHECK ON THAT BLATANT
LIE.
>> YOU DIDN’T DO A DAMN
THING.
THINK ABOUT IT.
THINK ABOUT WHAT HE DID NOT DO
AND IT’S ALMOST CRIMINAL.
>> THEY ALSO REPORT THAT
FORMER DEFENSE SECRETARY JAMES
MATTIS SAID TO TRUMP HAS NO
MORAL COMPASS.
>> WHAT’S CRIMINAL IS THE WAY
THE SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS ARE
PART OF THE BITING CAMPAIGN.
THEY WON’T TELL YOU THE FACTS
AND THAT’S WHY WE ARE DOING IT
HERE.
WE LAID OUT FOR YOU THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ACTIONS, BUT
THE ULTIMATE TEST IS THE
IMPACT, THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS WANT YOU TO LOOK AT
A NUMBER OF CASES BUT THAT’S
OBVIOUSLY MISLEADING AND
MEASURED TESTING.
AS YOU’VE SEEN WE’VE TEST MORE
THAN ANYBODY.
WERE TOLD RELENTLESSLY THAT
THIS OUTBREAK IS THE WORST IN
THE WORLD THAT TRUMP CAUSED A
SPIKE.
INTERESTING.
DID TRUMP ALSO CAUSE SPIKES IN
SPAIN AND FRANCE AND THE UK
AND GERMANY AND NEW ZEALAND,
LITERALLY EVERYWHERE?
ARE WE REALLY THE WORST IN THE
WORLD?
BIDEN AIDS ON TV LIKE CHUCK
TODD SAY WE HAVE 5% OF THE
WORLD’S POPULATION BUT 25% OF
THE DEATH.
THAT IS DISHONEST,
MISINFORMATION, ANTI- TRUMP
PROPAGANDA.
THEIR CALCULATION INCLUDES
COUNTRIES LIKE CHINA AND INDIA
AND AFRICA WITH VAST
POPULATIONS WE CAN’T TRUST
BECAUSE THEY LIE OR THEIR
HEALTH SYSTEMS ARE
INADEQUATE.
A FAIR AND HONEST COMPARISON
IS DEATH.
POPULATION.
HERE’S THE JOHN HOPKINS DATA.
WE ARE DOING BETTER THAN
MULTIPLE MAJOR COUNTRIES
INCLUDING THE UK, SPAIN AND
ITALY BUT AMERICA IS BIGGER
AND MORE DECENTRALIZED.
THE VIRUS RESPONSE HAS VARIED
STATE-BY-STATE AND WE GET A
VERY DIFFERENT PICTURE.
THE WORST CORONA RESPONSE IN
THE WORLD WAS NEW JERSEY RUN
BY DEMOCRATS FOLLOWED CLOSELY
BY NEW YORK RUN BY DEMOCRATS,
CUOMO WHO HAS THE NERVE TO
PUBLISH A BOOK AS HE TAKES A
VICTORY LAP.
HE CONDEMNED THEM TO DEATH BY
SENDING COVERT PATIENTS INTO
NURSING HOMES AND OH LOOK,
REPUBLICAN-LED STATES THAT THE
MEDIA LOVES TO CRITICIZE WHICH
HAVE MUCH LOWER RATES, BUT IF
THERE’S ONE MEASURE THAT GIVES
THE TRUEST PICTURE OF GLOBAL
PERFORMANCE IT IS THE
PROPORTION OF EXCESS DEATHS OF
A NORMAL YEAR END ON THAT
MEASURE, THE REAL MEASURE, HOW
MANY PEOPLE DIED COMPARED TO A
NORMAL YEAR.
NOT THE WORST IN THE WORLD,
WERE NOT EVEN CLOSE TO BEING
THE WORST.
WE HAVE IN FACT DONE BETTER
THAN NEARLY EVERY MAJOR
COUNTRY, BUT AN ELECTION IS A
CHOICE.
HOW WOULD BIDEN HANDLE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
WHEN HE FACED A PANDEMIC OF
H1N1 HE KEPT BORDERS WIDE
OPEN.
NO SURPRISE BUT HE IMPOSED
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S CHINA TRAVEL
BAN IN JANUARY.
BIDEN IS SO FRIGHTENED OF
BEING CALLED A RACIST BY THE
DEMOCRATS WOKE ACTIVISTS HE
CAN’T PROTECT US AGAINST
FOREIGN THREATS.
HE CAN GET THE VACCINES
EITHER.
LAST TIME HE PROMISED A
HUNDRED MILLION DOSES AND
DELIVER JUST ATTEND THE BAT.
FORTUNATELY H1N1 WAS MUCH LESS
DEADLY BUT BIDEN COMPLETELY
LOST CONTROL OF IT.
HE ADMITS.
>> HE DID EVERY POSSIBLE THING
WRONG AND IT 60 MILLION
AMERICANS I GOT H1 AND ONE IN
THAT TIME AND IT’S JUST PURELY
A FORTUITY THAT THIS ISN’T ONE
OF THE GREAT MASS CASUALTY
EVENTS IN HISTORY.
>> OF H1N1 HAD BEEN AS DEADLY
AS CORONAVIRUS THE DEATH TOLL
WOULD BEEN CLOSE TO 2 MILLION,
NOT 200,000, 2 MILLION.
AND THIS YEAR, ONE MONTH AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP SET UP THE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE, ONE
MONTH LATER ON THE NIGHT OF
HIS VICTORY, OUT OF 1418 WORDS
IN HIS VICTORY SPEECH THAT HE
TALKS ABOUT GUNS AND OBAMACARE
AND A BUNCH OF OTHER ISSUES
OUT OF 1418 WORDS, GUESS HOW
MANY BIDEN SPENT ON THE
PANDEMIC, ZERO.
HE DIDN’T EVEN MENTION IT.
SHOW THEM THE FACTS ON THEIR
RECORDS TRUMP BEATS BIDEN.
THE ELECTION IS A CHOICE ABOUT
FUTURE PLANS.
LET’S COMPARE.
BIDEN ANNOUNCED A PLAN TO MAKE
SURE NO ONE WOULD PAY FOR
GETTING CORONAVIRUS TREATMENT
AND INVOKE THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT AND PUT IN
COMMAND OFFICER IN CHARGE OF
THE VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
PLAN.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
TRUMP HAS DONE OR IS DOING,
BUT THERE ARE DIFFERENCES.
JIM INSTEAD OF SPEEDING UP
DEVELOPMENT, BIDEN IS ALL
ABOUT INCREASING IN HIS
PLATFORM WITH BERNIE, 19
SEPARATE PROPOSALS TO INCREASE
GOVERNMENT REGULATION AND
BUREAUCRATIC CONTROL OF
PHARMACEUTICALS.
BIDEN WANTS UNIVERSAL MASK
WEARING INCLUDING OUTDOORS.
THAT’S NOT JUSTIFIED BY THE
SCIENCE IT’S ENTIRELY
POLITICAL.
THEY SAY TRUMP KILLED PEOPLE
BECAUSE HE DIDN’T SHOW A LEAD,
BUT MANY COUNTRIES HAVE LEFT
MASKS WEARING EVEN THOUGH IT’S
ENCOURAGED.
IS THAT TRUMP’S FAULT TOO,
SOME OF THE COUNTRIES WHERE IT
WAS LEAST COMMON HAVE SOME OF
THE BEST RESULTS LIKE
AUSTRALIA.
BIDEN ALSO WANTS UNIFORM
NATIONWIDE STANDARDS.
>> THEY NEED REAL PLANS, REAL
GUIDELINES, UNIFORM NATIONWIDE
STANDARDS.
>> THAT IS INSANE.
THERE’S SOMETHING CALLED THE
CONSTITUTION.
WE BELIEVE IN FEDERALISM,
DIFFERENT STATES HAVE WILDLY
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES.
BIDEN WANTS TO IMPOSE THE
WORST RULES EVERYWHERE.
CALIFORNIA CHAOS,
COAST-TO-COAST, AND FINALLY OF
COURSE THIS EVENT SO IF THE
SCIENTISTS SAY SHUT IT DOWN I
WOULD SHUT IT DOWN.
>> OF COURSE HE WOULD.
HE’S A DEMOCRAT.
HE WANTS TO CONTROL
EVERYTHING.
THESE PSEUDOSCIENTIFIC,
THEY’RE NOT ABOUT CONTROLLING
THE VIRUS, THEREBY CONTROLLING
YOU WAS SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT
FLATTENING THE CURVE.
BIDEN WOULD FLATTEN THE
ECONOMY AND FLATTEN SOCIETY
TO.
KEEPING THE SCHOOLS CLOSE
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
OWNED BY THE TEACHING UNION.
THE PAIN AND HEARTBREAK OF
SMALL BUSINESSES CLOSING.
HEALTH CLUB, OPIOID, DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE, CHILD ABUSE, TEN
TIME LOSS TO THE SHUTDOWN OF
THE VIRUS ITSELF ACCORDING TO
THE DATA.
THAT’S WHAT YOU WOULD GET FROM
BIDEN, MORE MISERY, MORE PAIN
AND A LOT MORE GOVERNMENT AS
THEY EAGERLY SWOOPED IN TO
TAKE THE PLACE OF THE ECONOMY
AND SOCIETY THEY CRUSH.
THAT IS THE CHOICE ON
CORONAVIRUS WITH TRUMP
SUPPORTING THE STATES AND
OPENING THE ECONOMY AND BIDEN
SECOND-GUESSING THE STATES AND
SHUTTING IT DOWN.
PRIVATE SECTOR ENERGY OR
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY, A